8:00 P.M.
SEAN HANNITY RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: TUCKER, GREAT SHOW.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
BUCKLE UP, WE ARE GOING TO PUT
THIS ALL IN PERSPECTIVE.
MANY OF YOU MIGHT BE WORRIED
ABOUT THE ONGOING POLITICAL
TORNADOES AND HURRICANES OUT OF
THE SWAMP IN WASHINGTON.
THE MOB AND OUR CORRUPT MEDIA.
BY THE WAY, YOU SHOULD BE.
IT'S REPULSIVE WHAT THEY ARE
DOING AGAIN AFTER THREE YEARS OF
LIES AND CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW IT'S ALL
GOING TO PLAY OUT.
AND LIKELY MAY BE THE GO-AHEAD
AND IMPEACH PRESIDENT TRUMP OVER
NOTHING.
BILL CLINTON HAD 11 FELONIES IN
THE KENNETH STARR REPORT,
NOTHING HERE.
WE WILL SEE.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS WITH
CONFIDENCE, I CAN TELL YOU HOW
THIS IS GOING TO END AND IT'S
GOING TO END WITH THE REELECTION
OF DONALD TRUMP AND IN PART WE
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO THANK
THEM FOR WHAT THEY DID AND THEIR
STUPIDITY AND THEIR LACK OF
CONCERN FOR YOU, WE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, AND I CAN SEE THE
REPUBLICANS TAKING BACK THE
HOUSE, I COULD SEE REPUBLICANS
INCREASING THEIR MAJORITY IN THE
U.S. SENATE.
BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT.
THESE ARE DANGEROUS TIMES FOR A
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
BY THE WAY, GOD HELP US, IF THEY
EVER DID WIN WITH THEIR
$94 TRILLION GREEN NEW DEAL,
THERE ARE $36 TRILLION MEDICARE
FOR ALL WITH NO PRIVATE
INSURANCE, YOU SEE, THAT WOULD
DESTROY THE GREATEST ECONOMY
EVER DESIGNED BY MAN.
THAT'S A CLEAR AND PRESENT
DANGER.
DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE COMPLIANT
LAPDOG STENOGRAPHERS IN THE MOB
AND THE MEDIA, THEY ARE NOW
WILLING TO SHRED THE
CONSTITUTION COME UP AND THE
RULE OF LAW, SUSPEND ANY
CONNECTION TO TRUTH, REALITY,
OBJECTIVE TRUTH, AND BY THE WAY,
THEY WILL CAST AWAY ALL
GOD-GIVEN COMMON SENSE AS
ASSUMING THEY MIGHT'VE HAD SOME
IN THE BEGINNING TO SUBVERT THE
WILL OF YOU, WE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE ROOT CAUSE OF THIS NOW GOING
INTO ANOTHER IMPEACHMENT SAGA.
IT'S NOT BRIBERY, HIGH CRIMES,
MISDEMEANORS.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY EVIDENCE OF
THAT.
IT'S A PSYCHOTIC HATRED AND RAGE
AGAINST THIS PRESIDENT AND,
REALLY, FOR THOSE OF US WHO PUT
HIM IN OFFICE AND VOTED FOR HIM.
THEY NEVER RECOVERED FROM LOSING
IN 2016.
THEY THOUGHT THEY HAD THIS
COVERED.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THEY LOATHE WE
CAN MEET YOU THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WE SMELLY WALMART SHOPPERS.
I LOVE WALMART.
WE REDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES.
WE ARE AMERICANS THAT CLING TO
OUR GOD -- THANK YOU.
OUR GUNS, BIBLE, RELIGION.
THEY HATE YOU, THEY HATE ME,
THEY HATE THE PRESIDENT, AND
THEY LOOK DOWN ON ALL OF US,
THEY THINK THEY KNOW BETTER AND
THEY WANTS TOTAL CONTROL OF YOUR
LIFE, YOUR DECISIONS, AND THEY
WILL HACK YOU TO DEATH TO GET
THEIR SCHEME DONE.
THEY WANT TO CONFISCATE YOUR
MONEY, THEY WANT EVERYTHING
FREE, FREE, FREE FOR EVERYBODY.
CRADLE TO GRAVE, HIGHER
EDUCATION, FREE PAID VACATION,
FREE HOUSING, FREE HEALTHY FOOD,
FREE UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME
WHETHER YOU ARE WILLING OR
UNWILLING TO WORK -- BY THE WAY,
THEY WILL EMANATE OIL, GAS, THE
COMBUSTION ENGINE, EVENTUALLY
PLANES AND COWS.
CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, REAL SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE, NOW WANTS TO
PROVIDE -- THIS IS THE TRUTH,
WELFARE FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
INCLUDING CRIMINAL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THOSE CONVICTED.
THIS WOULD CAUSE AN ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION, THE LIKES OF WHICH
WE, THE U.S., THE WORLD HAS EVER
WITNESSED.
THIS IS THE GREATEST WEALTH
PRODUCING SYSTEM IN THE WORLD.
IT WOULD BE TURNED INTO ANOTHER
SOCIALIST HELL NO DIFFERENT FROM
VENEZUELA OR CUBA.
IN ORDER TO GOVERN THIS COUNTRY
WITH AN IRON FIST AND CARRY OUT
THAT SOCIALIST FREEDOM OF
THEIRS, THEY MUST RECLAIM POWER.
IT'S ALL ABOUT POWER.
YOU WOULD SAY, WE HAVE AN
ELECTION IN ONE YEAR.
WHY NOT LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DECIDE?
WELL, THE ANSWER TO THAT IS THEY
DON'T WANT TO RISK ANOTHER TERM
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP, SO THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY'VE GOT TO BLUDGEON IT
MORE.
IN A BACKFIRE BUT THAT IS THEIR
THINKING.
INSTINCTIVELY, I ARGUE THEY KNOW
THEY CAN'T WIN WITH THE PEOPLE
THEY HAVE RUNNING.
CONGRESSMAN AL GREEN SAID IT
BEST.
IF HE'S NOT IMPEACH, HE COULD
GET REELECTED.
LIKELY WELL.
TAKE A LOOK.
SPEAK ARE YOU CONCERNED
IMPEACHMENT TALK MAY HELP THE
PRESIDENT'S REELECTION?
>> I'M CONCERNED IF WE DON'T
IMPEACH THIS PRESIDENT, HE WILL
GET REELECTED.
IF WE DON'T IMPEACH HIM, HE WILL
STAY, HE'S BEEN VINDICATED.
>> Sean: IF WE DON'T IMPEACH
HIM, HE WILL GET REELECTED.
WHAT WE HAVE NOW BEEN THROUGH
THE LAST THREE YEARS, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, IMPEACH, IMPEACH,
STORMY, STORMY, IT'S CLEAR
DEMOCRATS ARE FULLY PREPARED TO
UP AND THE WILL OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY.
THEY THINK THEY KNOW BETTER THAN
WE DO.
BY THE WAY, THE DO-NOTHING
DEMOCRATS, WHAT HAVE THEY DONE?
WHAT A COMPLIMENT HAD THEY MADE
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS OF
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, TO MAKE YOU, WE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE MORE
PROSPEROUS, TO KEEP US MORE SAFE
AND MORE SECURE?
THEY HAVE DONE NOTHING.
THIS IS ALL THEY HAVE DONE FOR
THREE YEARS.
THEY WANT THIS POST CONSTITUTION
NOEL AMERICA.
THEY WANT
THEY WILL DECIDE EVERY NATIONAL
ELECTION.
THEY WANT TO GET RID OF THE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE THEY DON'T
LIKE HIM AND, BY THE WAY, EVEN
IF HE DOES SOMETHING THEY LIKE,
THEY DON'T LIKE HIM.
WHAT THE LEFT DOES FAIL TO
REALIZE TIME AND AGAIN IS THAT,
WELL, WE MIGHT BE A REDEEMABLE
DEPLORABLES THAT CLING TO OUR
GOD, BUT WE ARE ALSO HARDWORKING
LOGICAL SMART AMERICANS AND WE
WEREN'T, WELL, SWAMPED OUT OF
THE COMMON SENSE GOD GAVE US.
WE KNOW WHAT THIS IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY IS ALL ABOUT.
NOTHING MORE THAN A POLITICAL
STUNT.
THEY TRIED THIS FOR THREE YEARS
NOW.
THEY HAVE FAILED.
BY THE WAY, THIS TIME, THEY
AREN'T GOING TO PUT THEIR FAITH
AND HOPE IN ANOTHER SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR WHO IN THE END LET
THEM DOWN BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE.
WE ALL WITNESSED THEM SPIT
INSANE, BREATHLESS, NONSPOT
THREE YOUR HOAX, THE LIES,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, THE
WITCH HUNT.
THE SAME PEOPLE NOW, SAME
AGENDA, JUST A DIFFERENT
COUNTRY.
IT'S UKRAINE.
BY THE      BY THE WAY, UKRAINEH
BY THE      BY THE WAY, UKRAINEL
BY THE      BY THE WAY, UKRAINES
HILLARY CLINTON THE LAST
ELECTION AND THEY ADMIT IT.
BY THE WAY, A DNC OPERATIVE
SUBCONTRACTOR MET WITH UKRAINIAN
OFFICIAL TO GET DIRT ON TRUMP.
NOT TELLING THAT STORY EITHER.
WE THE PEOPLE, WE'VE BEEN
WATCHING THE WITNESSING THIS
PHONY, FAKE OUTRAGE, THIS MEDIA
CIRCUS, THE CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION, THE SMEARING --
OH, THE PRESIDENT, JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH, WE WITNESSED A
16-YEAR-OLD HIGH SCHOOL KID GET
DEMONIZED ON NATIONAL TV FOR
WEARING A MAGA HAT.
THEY ASSASSINATED HIS CHARACTER.
YOU'VE BEEN WITNESSING THE MEDIA
MOB AND THEY ARE A MOB WITH A
MOP MIND-SET, BREATHLESS
HYSTERIA, RESULTED IN ONE FAKE
PHONY STORY AFTER ANOTHER, ONE
LIE AFTER ANOTHER.
EVERY SECOND OF EVERY DAY.
WE GOT THEM, WE GOT THEM -- NO,
YOU DON'T.
THE GREAT IRONY IN ALL OF THIS,
WHATEVER ACCUSATIONS DEMOCRATS
AND THE MOB LAUNCHED AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, THEY END OF BEING
GUILTY OF THAT VERY THING
THEMSELVES.
HOW IRONIC.
THIS IS WHY TONIGHT I WANT YOU
TO TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT THIS
LIST.
BY THE WAY, THOSE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMEN AND WOMEN, THEY
REPRESENT DISTRICTS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP CARRIED IN 2016.
NOW, IF YOU LIVE IN ANY OF THOSE
DISTRICTS, IT MIGHT BE IMPORTANT
TO REMIND YOUR LAWMAKER THAT
THEY WORK FOR YOU, AND NOT DOING
ANYTHING IN THREE YEARS IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE TO YOU.
IT'S TO ALLOW THE CORRUPT,
COWARDLY, ADAM, THE SHIFTY
SCHIFF, LITERALLY RUN THIS
THING, THESE PEOPLE NEED TO
STAND UP TO THIS POST
CONSTITUTIONAL COUP ATTEMPT IN
THEIR PARTY AND FRANKLY I SAY
DEFEAT THEM.
THIS IS WHERE YOU HAVE THE
POWER, NOT THEM.
THE RADICAL FAR LEFT EXTREME
SOCIALIST IN CHARGE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THINK THEY RULE
IT ALL.
YOU WILL HAVE THE LAST SAY AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
THE COWARDLY SCHIFF AND AOC AND
TLAIB AND PELOSI, THEY GET YOUR
WAY, THE SANCTITY OF THEIR
VOTES, THIS REPUBLIC WILL BE
DESTROYED BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
WANT TO FUNDAMENTALLY,
DRASTICALLY RESHAPED AMERICA.
AND ADAM, THE COWARDLY SHIFTY
SCHIFF, IN PARTICULAR HE IS
TRYING TO CALL AND WE THE PEOPLE
WITH LIES AND FABRICATIONS.
WE KNOW THAT THE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER, WELL, FROM THE
UKRAINE CALL, WORKED WITH
SCHIFF'S OFFICE TO CRAFT THE
COMPLAINT.
IN FACT I MUST BE 24'S OFFICE
ENCOURAGED THE WHISTLE-BLOWER TO
HIRE A LAWYER, GO TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
ON NATIONAL TV, THE SHIFTY
SCHIFF, HE SAID I HAVE NOT
SPOKEN WITH THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
BUT WE'D LIKE TO.
THAT WAS A LIE TOO.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY THE FAKE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WAS A BLUR FAILED
TO MENTION HIS CONTACT WITH
SCHIFF'S OFFICE IN THE COMPLAINT
SCHIFF'S OFFICE IN THE COMPLAIN.
OUR OWN CATHERINE HERRIDGE, THIS
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER, AND WE HAVE
MORE BECAUSE THAT WAS NOT
PANNING OUT, WE HAVE TONS OF
WHISTLE-BLOWERS, WILL MAKE THEM
UP.
FILING THE COMPLAINT, LEFT A
SECTION WHICH THEY COULD'VE
DISCLOSED, THAT CONGRESSIONAL
CONTACT, THEY DIDN'T USE IT.
STILL NO WORD WHY THERE WAS ALSO
AN 18 DAY GAP IN BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT'S CALL WITH UKRAINE
AND THE URGENT REPORT MADE TO
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
MAYBE THE COWARDLY SCHIFF HAS
NOT BEEN CONTACTED BY THAT
POINT.
MAYBE HE KNOWS THE ANSWER.
MAYBE SCHIFF CAN ALSO FILL US IN
WHY THE FAKE, PHONY
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER IS REPORTEDLY
A REGISTERED DEMOCRAT HIRED TO
WORK IN THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE,
WENT TO HIS OFFICE OF ALL PLACES
TO FILE THE COMPLAINT.
MAYBE THE COWARDLY SHIFT CAN
TELL US HOW THE PRESIDENT'S
PHONE CALL WITH WORLD LEADERS
ARE NOW GETTING LEAKED AGAIN AND
AGAIN TO THE PRESS.
AUSTRALIA, MEXICO, UKRAINE,
AUSTRALIA AGAIN.
NO OTHER PRESIDENT IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY HAS HAD
TO DEAL WITH THIS ONSLAUGHT FROM
A DEEP STATE BUREAUCRACY SWAMPED
FROM WITHIN.
ONLY DONALD TRUMP AND NOW WE ARE
SEEING MORE LEAKS FROM MORE
WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
NO END TO THE WHISTLE-BLOWERS
THAT AREN'T WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
THAT DIDN'T WORK OUT.
WE'LL FIND SOME MORE.
THEY DON'T NEED TO HEAR FROM
ANYONE BY THE WAY BECAUSE WE
HAVE A TRANSCRIPT.
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT THEY THINK
OR HOW THEY INTERPRETED HEARSAY
INFORMATION.
SO TO SCHIFF OR ANYONE IN THE
SWAMP ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT REAL
NATIONAL SECURITY RAMIFICATIONS,
WHAT IF THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO
TALK TO A WORLD LEADER FRANKLY
ABOUT ISSUES OF WAR AND PEACE?
IS THAT GOING TO BE SPITE ON
TOO?
TO THE CARE ABOUT OUR DIPLOMACY
NOW THAT IT SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPAIRED BECAUSE OF THESE LEAKS,
CLEARLY NOT.
DON'T EXPECT TO GET AN HONEST
ANSWER FROM SCHIFF ANNIE
DEMOCRAT FOR THAT MATTER AND
CERTAINLY DON'T EXPECT YOUR
LYING CORRUPT MOB MEDIA TO DO
THEIR JOBS.
ALL THEY CARE ABOUT IS TAKING
DOWN DONALD TRUMP NO MATTER
WHAT.
UNDOING AND ELECTION OF WE, THE
PEOPLE, WE
THEY ARE ALL PROVEN
LIARS, EVERY ONE OF THEM.
IT'S A DIFFERENT COUNTRY.
NOW UKRAINE, NOT RUSSIA.
I CAN'T THINK OF A SINGLE ISSUE
THEY DIDN'T LIE ABOUT.
OUR OWN GREGG JARRETT POINTED
OUT SCHIFF ALONE LIGHT ABOUT
CARTER PAGE GETTING PAID BY THE
KREMLIN, LIED ABOUT THE
DISSEMINATION ABOUT THE DIRTY
DOSSIER, SPEECH AND IF I LIED
WHEN HE CLAIMED THE DIRTY
DOSSIER WAS NOT THE BULK OF
INFORMATION IN THE FILE THE
APPLICATION AGAINST, AND WHO
CAN FORGET THAT SCHIFF LIED
REPEATEDLY ALLEGEDLY TO HAVE THE
DAMNING EVIDENCE PROVING
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
THAT DIDN'T WORK OUT, DID IT?
FOR YEARS, THERE HE IS THE
COWARDLY SHIFTY SCHIFF, HE'S
LIED OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
FRANKLY NOT ONLY CENSURED,
INCORPORATED YOU SHOULD NOT BE
IN CHARGE OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YES, THERE IS AMPLE EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION IN PLAIN SIGHT.
WE'VE KNOWN FOR SOME TIME IT'S
BEEN PUBLICLY REPORTED THAT THE
DOSSIER, OR THE HIRING OF
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, WAS
INITIALLY ON THE BEHALF OF ONE
THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES AND
LATER ON BEHALF OF DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES.
THAT APPLICATION AND THOSE
RENEWALS HAVE BEEN VINDICATED IN
SUBSTANTIAL PART BY CARTER
PAGE'S OWN WORDS.
WELL, I CERTAINLY THINK HE'S
ACTING LIKE SOMEONE WHOSE
COMPROMISE AND IT VERY
VERY WELL MAY BE THAT HE'S
COMPROMISED BY THE RUSSIANS WHO
HAVE INFORMATION ON HIM.
>> ACCORDING TO CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, AND FORMER BRITISH
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER WHO HAS
REPORTEDLY BEEN HELD IN HIGH
REGARD BY U.S. INTELLIGENCE,
RUSSIAN SOURCES TELL HIM THAT
PAIGE HAD A SECRET MEETING WITH
CEO GAS GIANT RUSS NET.
OFFERED BROKERAGE FEES ON A DEAL
INVOLVING A 19% SHARE OF THE
COMPANY.
I HEAR WHAT YOU WANT.
I HAVE A FAVOR I WANT FROM YOU,
THOUGH.
AND I'M GOING TO SAY THIS ONLY
SEVEN TIMES AND SO YOU BETTER
LISTEN GOOD.
I WANT YOU TO MAKE UP DIRT ON MY
POLITICAL OPPONENT AND
UNDERSTAND LOTS OF IT.
ON THIS AND ON THAT.
>> Sean: HE IS A LIAR.
HE IS A PATHOLOGICAL -- FRANKLY,
CONGENITAL LIAR.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE LIES,
THOUGH.
IT'S THE COMPLETE AND UTTER
HYPOCRISY FELLOW DEMOCRATS AND
THE MEDIA MOB, THEY ALL DO THE
SAME THING.
SCHIFF ALLEGED TO HAVE ALL THE
EVIDENCE TO PROVE IT.
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION, BUT HE'S
THE GUY CAUGHT ON TAPE TRYING TO
GET THERE FROM SOMEBODY THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A RUSSIAN THAT HE
THOUGHT WAS A RUSSIAN.
IN FACT, HE TOOK THAT DIRECT
CALL FROM TWO PRANKSTERS WHO
CLAIMED TO HAVE [RUSSIAN ACCENT]
NAKED PICTURES OF TRUMP,
COMPROMISING MATERIALS ON TRUMP.
DOES VLADIMIR KNOW?
[RUSSIAN ACCENT]
VLADIMIR KNOWS ECONOMIZING THEY
CAN MATERIALS OF TRUMP.
MARK WARNER?
HE'S NOT EVEN BETTER.
NO EVIDENCE OF ANY COLLUSION,
INCLUDING HIS OWN BIPARTISAN
PROBE IN THE SENATE.
WARNER STILL CLAIMS THAT TRUMP
MIGHT'VE COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA
ANYWAY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, LIPSEY
DAISY, SENATOR WARNER WAS BUSY
TEXTING A LOBBYIST FOR A RUSSIAN
OLIGARCH TO GET DIRT ON TRUMP.
WARNING THE OLIGARCH TO SET UP A
PRIVATE MEETING WITH NONE OTHER
THAN CHRISTOPHER STEELE WITHOUTA
THAN CHRISTOPHER STEELE WITHOUTY
THAN CHRISTOPHER STEELE WITHOUTE
THAN CHRISTOPHER STEELE WITHOUTU
THAN CHRISTOPHER STEELE WITHOUTL
THAN CHRISTOPHER STEELE WITHOUTC
THAN CHRISTOPHER STEELE WITHOUTN
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE,
KNOWING WHAT THEY ARE DOING OR
WHAT THEY ACCUSED TRUMP OF.
ACTUALLY TEXTED THE LOBBYIST FOR
THE OLIGARCH, I WOULD LIKE TO DO
A PRELIMINARY CALL.
HUMAN, ME, NO ONE ELSE.
WARNER ALSO TEXTING NOT HAVE A
PAPER TALE WITH HIS MESSAGES
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIANS.
SENATOR INDICATING HE BE WILLING
TO TRAVEL ABROAD, TO MEET WITH
STEELE TO GET THE DIRT ON TRUMP
AND MANAFORT.
WHAT THEY ARE BLAMING TRUMP OF!
NOT A GOOD LOOK FOR SOMEONE WHO
DOES A FILES ALL FOR AN ELECTION
INTERFERENCE, AND HE'S NOT THE
ONLY DEMOCRATIC SENATOR GUILTY
OF WHICH THEY ARE ACCUSING TRUMP
OF WHICH THEY ARE ACCUSING TRUMO
OF WHICH THEY ARE ACCUSING TRUM.
SEND LETTERS FROM
SENATOR MENENDEZ, DURBIN, LAHEY,
THEY THREATEN TO WITHHOLD AID IF
THE GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE
STOPPED INVESTIGATING TRUMP ON
THE TRUMP-RUSSIA SIDE.
MEETING WITH UKRAINE'S NEW
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY, DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR CHRIS MURPHY THREATENED
TO CUT OFF U.S. AID IF THE
PRESIDENT DOWN THE COUNTRY OPENS
AN INVESTIGATION TO BIDEN.
DO NOT FORGET POLITICO'S REPORT
ABOUT A DNC OPERATIVE,
JANUARY 11TH 2017 THEY WROTE
THIS, AND OPERATIVE WORKING FOR
THE DNC, A CONTRACTOR, WORKING
WITH UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT TO GET
COMPROMISING MATERIALS TO SMEAR
THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP TO HELP
SMEAR AND THEN BOLSTER HILLARY.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION, THEY'VE GOT
MORE THAN $50,000 IN DONATIONS
FROM UKRAINIAN CITIZENS THAN ANY
OTHER FOREIGN COUNTRY.
IMAGINE IF VICE PRESIDENT
TRUMP -- NOT BIDEN'S SON, LET'S
SAY IT WAS HUNTER TRUMP, NO
EVIDENCE, NO BACKGROUND IN
UKRAINE OR CHINA, AND DID WHAT
HUNTER DID WHILE HIS DAD WAS
VICE PRESIDENT?
NOT A WORD ON ANY OF THIS FROM
YOUR CORRUPT MOB IN THE MEDIA.
THE ONLY THING THEY DO, THE
DO-NOTHING DEMOCRATS, THEY ONLY
CARE ABOUT THREE YEARS NOW GET
RID OF TRUMP, NOTHING ELSE,
NOTHING ELSE.
MEANWHILE, LOOK AT THE
PRESIDENT.
HE'S BEEN TIRELESSLY WORKING DAY
AFTER DAY, KEEPING HIS PROMISES,
IMPROVING THE LIVES OF WE THE
PEOPLE.
WE ARE SEEING RESULTS, 7 MILLION
NEW JOBS.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH DESPITE
THE CONSTANT UNYIELDING
RESISTANCE FROM THE DEEP STATE,
MEDIA MOB, AND THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THAT DOES NOTHING.
TWO ORIGINAL LISTS FROM THE
SUPREME COURT FROM THE LIST HE
GAVE US.
JOBLESS CLAIMS, THE LOWEST SINCE
1969.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, HISPANIC
AMERICANS, AND YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT.
ENERGY DEPENDENT FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN 79 YEARS AND I CAN GO ON
AND ON.
PROMISES MADE, PROMISES KEPT.
THIS IS WHAT 2020 IS REALLY
ABOUT.